hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast turning to a new
dimension and cell culture for cancer
research presented by Carl Amin carlitz
postdoctoral research fellow at pharmacy
Northwest University
I am Alexis Krause elaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab birds and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher comm now let's get started before
I begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button once
there's many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left
year screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
ium credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Carter McCulloh dr.
chemists completed her PhD in
pharmaceutics in 2017 her thesis focused
on the establishment of
three-dimensional cell culture models
for drug bio transformation and toxicity
studies she was awarded the South
African national research foundation
innovation doctoral scholarship and
travel award in 2016 and 2017 with this
award she was able to spend six months
at the University of Southern Denmark in
Odense Denmark learning the art of
three-dimensional spheroid culturing
since 2014 she has published five first
author publications and international
peer-reviewed journals dr. colleagues is
currently employed and the Faculty of
Health Sciences at the nwu of the
postdoctoral research fellow focusing on
the development of three-dimensional
cell culture models and platforms for
cancer
biotransformation and toxicity screening
of preclinical lead compounds or
traditional herbal medicine for a
complete biography on doctor colleagues
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. college you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction good
morning my name is dr. Karen McComas and
before I start I would like to thank a
get-go and thermo Fisher Scientific
especially Chelsea for giving me the
opportunity to talk to you today about
one of my great passions in life
three-dimensional cell culturing
specifically swearword cultures and that
amazing shift in cancer research just a
bit of geographical and general
information for those of you do not know
where the Northwest University is we are
one of the biggest universities in South
Africa catering for approximately 80,000
students with three campuses and eight
faculty I am situated on the porch of
Sturm campus in the center of excellence
for pharmaceutical sciences within the
Faculty of Health Sciences
all in a little town called porch of
Sturm I am currently a postdoctoral
fellow responsible together of my fellow
postdoc doctor Clarissa bullish for the
establishment of Newark and models
working under the guidance of a
wonderful host dr. Krishna host and
professor C are common and here at the
North West University we excited a
paradigm shift in terms of senators are
mentioned in an attempt to better
understand and answer cancer as a
disease and the treatment thereof
it is concerning to know the cancer
results in more depth than AIDS
tuberculosis and malaria combined can
statistics indicate an estimated 8.2
million annual deaths worldwide with 46
of these cancer deaths attributed to
lung liver stomach or bowel cancer
understanding these them our
understanding this disease and finding
the base treatment is of utmost
importance
currently pharmaceutical research and
development is spending billions of
dollars to get new more effective drugs
on the market this is a very costly and
timely business when you look at the
high incidence of drugs attrition rates
the costliest in terms of the lives the
payment on these drug discoveries
high drive attrition rates are mostly
attributed to the fact that gap exists
between a current in vitro and in vivo
models and ultimately humans this
development of those developments in the
use of appropriate in vitro and in vivo
cancer models is highly desirable the
current gold standard in in vitro and in
vivo preclinical cancer drug treatment
screening remain primary cell cultures
and cancer cell lines grown on static
flat two-dimensional surfaces and animal
models that mating mainly include
rodents such as hamsters rice associate
press and mice
two dimensional funnel cultures of the
various advantages in that culturing
conditions are highly controlled with a
high degree of homogeneity and
reproducibility allowing for the
discovery of molecular mechanisms the
system has also contributed
significantly to our knowledge of tumor
biology while stimulating cancer
research in terms of drug discovery and
development furthermore the low cost and
the simplicity of this model also
attributes to its popularity
unfortunately the system also comes with
implementation including phenotypic and
genotypic adaptations to individual
conditions as well as the accumulation
of mutations furthermore the system is
limited in terms of cytotoxicity assay
and partly accounts for the high rate of
drug failure and being an isolated
homogeneous population of cells removes
these cells from the true tumor
microenvironment with a lack of cell
cell communication
cell matrix interactions and also a lack
of tissue specific architecture on the
other hand animal models have been used
for many years in cancer research and
drug discovery and remains the
prerequisite in preclinical drug
screenings according to the fda cancer
mouse models have revolutionized our
ability to study gene expression and
protein function and more closely
resemble human physiology
however these models tend to be
expensive and time-consuming furthermore
animal models too frequently fail to
reflect the true Yuma tumor biology
these models are in some instances
immunocompromised and present with sex
and specie differences and not all
cancer cell types have a suitable animal
model yet most importantly they come
with ethical and moral considerations
so to bridge the gap between this
shortcoming of current in vitro and in
vivo models we are turning to a new
dimension in cell culturing in order to
understand why we have to look at the
human body organs and tumors both a
unique three-dimensional cellular
architecture with established
communication networks that allows cells
to communicate with each other as well
as with the extracellular matrix yeats
two-dimensional cell cultures like this
cell cell communication the sol matrix
interaction and also tissue specific
architecture an animal models fail to
reflect the true human tumor biology so
how do we bridge this gap it is true
that the base model for man is men
however it is not typically allowed to
taste on humans without some form of
prior toxicological evaluation of a new
lead compound for the establishment of
three-dimensional cell culture systems
it was found a three dimensional cell
culturing offers a better correlation to
this in vivo situation as
three-dimensional models offer a more
natural shape geometry and morphology of
cells with established cell to cell
communication regulatory mechanisms and
signaling networks also 3d constructs
tend to adopt the tissue like structure
making them more physiologically
relevant to fully appreciate the
statement we have to look at some very
important and distinct differences
between two and three dimensional cell
culturing the table here shows some of
the major differences between these two
models I'm briefly going to go through a
few of things one of the most striking
differences between 2d and 3d culturing
is the culturing time 2d cultures have a
limited working window usually days to
weeks while some 3d systems have working
windows from weeks to months due to the
unnatural two-dimensional micro
environment of cells in 2d important
metabolism and biochemical features are
altered
that has an influence on the
pharmacological drug responses also due
to the geometrical and morphological
differences of influence cells
cytoskeleton gene and protein expression
responsible for solely responsible those
responses are influenced in
three-dimensional cultures cells find
themselves in a more natural geometrical
and morphological shape resulting in
some instances in the formation of in
vivo like tissue structures that
provides more clinical relevant data
more representative of the in either
condition and comparable to animal
studies
in cancer research the differences in
the cell cycle kinetics and further
serration rates of these two models are
of major concern the cell cycle is a
series of events that results in the
duplication and division of cells the
components responsible for cell growth
and division also influences cell
differentiation controlling the cell
cycle is of utmost importance as cancer
in many instance attribute to this is
attributed to the dysregulation of this
cell cycle within the human body
most cells find themselves with in the
g0 g1 phase thus with some cells
actively replicating but most cells no
longer dividing but carrying out
specialized functions cells within two
dimensional cultures find themselves
within a continuous growth phase and are
actively replicating due to the need for
subsequent sub culturing upon reaching
confluency where cell aggregates within
free deacons as flower cultures find
themselves in various stages of the cell
cycle
it is these critical differences that
culminate into discrepancies towards
drug responses and it also suggests the
3d models might be more apt at providing
insight as to how cancer and specific
organ systems will react to lead
anti-cancer compounds so various
three-dimensional culture systems are
available and it should be stressed that
not one method is superior to the other
a natural research question available
resources will determine which system
you will employ pre dimensional systems
can be broadly classified into static
and dynamic or irrigated systems static
systems as the classifications suggest
is static non-moving systems these
include but are not limited to hanging
drop cultures for floating devices like
removing and printing devices galactose
related substrates 3d scaffold
and familiar dishes while dynamic or
irrigated system suggests a solar system
that has moving parts these systems
usually include spinner flasks March
automatic devices marked by reactors or
rotating by reactors as you can see in
this quick video of 19 seconds
the field of three-dimensional style
coaching is very broad indeed and it
will most probably take more than one
webinar to cover all of them and for
this reason I will focus only on
three-dimensional multi service
throughout culture a third is defined as
a spherical symmetrical aggregate of
solves analogous to tissue series of
seen as heterogeneous aggregates the
cells that are proliferating equations
and retain the 3d architecture with a
capability to reestablish the tissue
specific functions
multicenter spirits are also capable of
mimicking in vivo processes such as
embryogenesis morphogenesis and
organogenesis three-dimensional spirit
models possesses several in evil like
features of tumors including salty style
interactions hypoxia drug penetration
response and resistance as well as the
production and no deposition of
extracellular matrix various cell lines
are capable of forming multicellular
thyroid structures exhibiting in vivo
like physiological conditions for
instance cardiomyocyte spirits that beat
with heartbeat like rhythms hepatocytes
words that perform live alike functions
with liver like structure and even brain
organoid reaches the researchers are now
also considering the use of spirit to
build BIOS fabricated 3d functional
living micro tissues and organs
constructs by means of organ printing
that will further enhance the field of
tissue engineering
the swingers can be with us by various
means as I said some spent a flask self
aggregation hanging drop cultures and
rotating bioreactors in our laboratory
we employ the Salvi buh-bum system that
is a Klein estat based system using
rotating bioreactor
now for those of you do not know a
kleiner stat is a rotating device that
has been around since the 1920s that was
designed to allow a plant to experience
equal amounts of gravitational pull over
360 degrees in this way there is little
to no gravitational pull on the plow
plant allowing on the plant to overcome
instances of positive phototropism or
geotropism the same principles account
for cells grown in a Kline estate
bioreactor in that the gravitational
pull is lessened on the salt it should
be noted that the gravitational forces
cannot be overcome in an elaborate
laboratory environment so when
researchers usually mention a
microgravity bioreactor they are
actually referring to a climber set
based bioreactor the cellular bomb
system is a next-generation Linus tech
based system that comes with a driving
unit an environmental control a wireless
control system with one of the most
user-friendly interfaces and
surprisingly the Northwest University is
also a trying site for this
salvadore bomb system
so swear words and organize for use with
the system can be created by various
means so you can use a durable plates
from stem cell technologies or the
spherical plate 5d from Google Myers
microgravity micro carrier beads
hydrogel like sodium alginate matrigel
or cue gel and south aggregation from
single cell suspensions these methods
and products are probably not the only
products that you can use to producers
so you need to establish a method that
suits your needs but is based on your
cell type the research question and your
available resources so in our labs we
prefer to work with the agar plates and
sodium alginate the rotating bike
reactors developed by Rafael vivo are
fixed volume bioreactors that come is
already assembled these bio reactors
have a cell chamber with two openings
that allows the forming and medium
exchange and a water chamber with a wick
to generate humidity the cell chamber
and water chamber is separated by 0.2
micron membrane and the gas exchange
labyrinth on the water chamber allows
for optimum oxygen and carbon dioxide
exchange because it is a closed system
instances of contamination and infection
within cultures are also kept to a
minimum what I would also like to say
about the fixed volume of the bio
reactors is that this allows us
specifically in toxicological or
cytotoxicity studies to administer
dosage according to the weight and
according to a fixed volume so in
different systems usually the volume is
different and it makes dosing very hard
a guerilla place begin allows us to
generate up to 1200 sized controlled
steroids
per well was in 24 hours of the feeding
this gives us ample biological assays
harmful materials
after information the Admirals fluids
are transferred to the rotating
bioreactors which is being placed on the
bum rotating system
swear is produced in this way can add a
physiological functionality for a period
of 42 days with the stewards reaching a
metabolic equilibrium around 21 days
this means that your experimental design
is now not limited to five or seven days
as with traditional two-dimensional
cultures but now you can conduct
experiments over a 21 day period so
let's look at how you would approach
this establishment of a new multi study
this word model currently we are trying
very hard to establish lung cancer
square roots which we hope to publish by
the end of this year so this was the
steps we took in establishing it the
first order of business for us was to
get to know a fair line as well as the
organ of origin and the attributes of
the specific answer and this allowed us
to determine what we would be catch
characterizing during the establishment
of this model for instance we asked
questions are we interested in the
expression of certain proteins jeans or
transporters you can ask yourself also
what the native organ looked like and
what kind of functionalities it performs
so the Deering characterization you can
beam determine if it resembles the
native physiological the geological
functionality and Anatomy this is
probably one of the most important tips
because if you don't understand yourself
or what your what your question is you
do not know what to look for and how to
go about the next steps then you will
continue to put determined growth
characteristics overnight enough sorry
first he has to create the spirit model
using your desire technique and then you
will continue to determine to determine
the growth characteristics such as y0
and viability and functionality of your
cell line in both two-dimensional
cultures as well as field as well as
your three-dimensional spirit cultures
and finally you will attempt to validate
your model by means of well published
and established anti-cancer model
compounds
so after familiarizing yourself with all
the literature available regarding a
cell line and the type of cancers you
are investigating you can begin to
develop your Seward models
this step will require some optimization
and patience as different cell types or
behaves differently in both the actual
and sodium alginate as well as as your
choice of method to create your spirits
so feeding densities time within the egg
rolls angular size the stiffness of the
sodium alginate gel valve shape the
culture medium requirements of the salt
all of this will come into play as all
of the these attributes will influence
the formation of spheroids and it's
marker environment so as a rule in our
laboratory when we start off we start
off by feeding a thousand cells per
micro role in each ed level we then use
the salt form swards for 24-hour period
and then remove them from the outer
walls and place them within the
bioreactors and then we monitor the
rotation speed according to the growth
rate and the size of the stewards this
is also a very important step with our
systems however we have noticed but not
all cell lines adhere to these
conditions as you can see in the images
display beer in images 1 2 & 3 we have
the cell line that behaved perfectly and
conform to all the state conditions
making the most beautiful perfect
flurries we have ever seen and then we
went to the next line which you can see
in image 4 5 & 6
this gave us somewhat of the headaches
after we seeded the cells we came to the
lab the next morning very excited and
upon inspection of the egg rolls it
appeared that the fluids formed were not
usable however being the the ever
optimistic one I see to Clarissa let's
remove them from the world and indeed we
had perfect swearwords
and finally
seven eight and nine shows a salon that
did not want to conform to to the state
conditions and required 48 hours within
the adderall's before so information
even then the spirits are not as we
would want them however as you can see
in image ten and eleven after being
placed within the rotating bioactives
these turrets formed beautiful spherical
aggregates within six days so in our
laboratories all these models could be
maintained through a period of 30 days
of the slurry formation by careful speed
adjustment and regular medium changes
so ah we have a good view of model and
now we have to characterize this model
so that we know what this model can and
cannot do with your characterization in
2d as well as in 3d so as we can
determine if indeed growing cells in
spherical aggregates affects the
functionality or not
characterization involves many steps
depending on the model that you are
developing and you may even find that in
your lab you can probably add something
to this or even do it in different ways
once again and this is very important
resources and research question will
determine what will be most important in
each instance in our laboratory we first
determine the growth characteristics of
a two of the two models in the 3d model
that is really done by taking daily
fights photo mastered micrographs of
your thyroids and conducting econometric
measurements of the sewers using
software like image j which is freely in
the 2d model growth characteristics can
be determined by means of South counting
all Axela gence we then determine the
protein content of first 3d and the 2d
models on a daily basis and on
laboratories we use the bracketed essays
quite easy to come by and not too
expensive but once again there are many
other protein determination keeps
available so why do we do it once you
start your growth characteristics you
will notice that there are striking
differences in the doubling time of 2d
and 3d cultures in the edges to see 3a3
words we notice a fall in the growth
rate in the 3d cultures of the 21 days
also to circumvent some of the
difficulties associated with performing
the quantitative cytotoxicity studies in
3d cultures such as the inability to can
solve with in spirit and also the
particulate nature of we attempt to make
the data relatable to inveigle animal
studies by determining the amount of
protein present
so during characterization we take photo
micrographs daily and then we measure
the circumference of the shadow area of
the sphere spheroid by using image shape
and then after that we determine the
protein content using the Bradford assay
and then by plotting the planimetric
data as a function of the protein
content we find that there is a clear
correlation so this allows us then to
set up in the crop table to allow you to
only perform the non-destructive
standing metric measurements in off
following studies and then simply relate
them to the protein content such a
lookup table will differ obviously for
each cell line as each sign line will
probably produce different sized square
roots and for certain protein contents
so it should be individually set up for
each new steroid model so to make the
life even more easier we then make 2d
data more relatable to our 3d data by
applying the same principle just the 2d
data you can actually count yourself so
once again we take photomicrographs
after seeding solving 96-well plates and
then we count them by means of image j
after that we perform the protein
grunting determination and then we can
relate the number of cells to the amount
of protein and we can also set up a
lookup table in both instances these
calculations allows us to administer
dosages during our experiments and
predict preclinical drug trials in terms
of milligram per kilogram that is more
relatable to your in vivo studies
we also do daily viability checks this
is usually the least fun part of the
study but by measuring the interest and
ATP concept and the extracellular
adrenalized and edema night kinase and
lactate dehydrogenase release we can
determine the viability so and this is
also can also be determined by different
means and various kits are available so
you will just have to to figure out what
suits you the best
so the intracellular ATP levels and the
adding realized kinase levels offer us a
valuable insight into the viability of
our system over time it is very
important to determine the viability of
your system and this will influence your
working with us and the results you can
expect here we have some images images C
and E respectively show results from the
intracellular ATP levels and analyzed
kinase levels of 2d cultures over four
days an image D and F shows the interest
and ATP levels and adenylate kinase
release of 3d cultures over 21 day
period from this data because most we
could determine that the best time to
work with 2d cultures to the date the
most accurate results would be from day
one to three whereas for 3d cultures we
only start to work from day 17 or 21 up
until day 42
determining functionality will depend on
the system and the research question and
the time point should be set up
accordingly samples for proteomics are
collected as often as possible at
various time points and then you can
also do confocal imaging Easter
chemistry and transmission electron
microscopy and as this provides insight
into any structural differences between
the two systems over time and should be
conducted at various time points some of
our most exciting discoveries in terms
of the differences between 2d and 3d
systems will most probably come from the
functionality and proteomic as well as
the imaging data observing the hgtc
through a deliverer steroids and
traditional 2d cultures of the four days
and culture using a transmission
electron microscope found that both the
cultures presented with organelles
normally found in eukaryotic cells like
mitochondria nuclei and depressed
reticulum and so forth however the
swearwords
exhibited additional features not often
seen in 2d cultures such as the
formation of liver like structures in
the form of bile chemically like
stretches like as glycogen granules and
sinusoidal live channels packed with
long villi
other functionality tests not shown here
indicate that 3d cultures produce more
urea and bowel compared to the 2d
counterparts of the 21 days also the
proteomic data offers wonderful insight
such as the nuclear rearrangement by the
skeletor's rearrangement the reduced
protein oxidation and the production of
hemoglobin for more insights into some
of our established fluid systems and the
differences between 2d and 3d culture
please see the lists of publications at
the end of this presentation I hope you
found this webinar insightful and that
you are all now ready to make this by
mentions shift by realizing the
three-dimensional fluids offer an
exciting model to investigate in vivo
functionality we solve the growing
conditions that are not drastically
different to those seen in real tissue
as in contrast to the classical
two-dimensional cell culturing for more
insights to some of the products
mentioned and the cell vivo bomb system
please view the list of websites at the
end I hope you will also join our
following webinar where my colleague the
doctor Clara sellers will discuss the
validation and the application of our
new spirit models Thanks
thank you dr. collie for that
informative presentation we will now
fertilize Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is named the most
inexpensive technique to the two
develops your thyroid culture
for us that will be sodium alginate that
is probably the most inexpensive
technique to develop spirit cultures
with
our next question is
why do you say the 3d spheroid model is
more relevant specifically in regards to
your comments about the cell cycle
um treaty cells are usually in a
continuous growth phase whereas 3d cells
are in both a continuous growth phase as
well as in a non producing but non
proliferating yet metabolically active
state and this is more like the in vivo
situation and for that reason we use
them in regards to the cell cycle
what is the reproducibility between
separate experiments of these steroids
created in the clinic clinic based
system especially between different
bioreactors and it's actually quite
quite reproducible when we shake up or a
protein table I think the experiments
were done about 800 times case and that
is how we got our labels up like that so
it's quite quite reproducible I've done
these experiments in in our labs in
South Africa I've overdone them in our
and the labs at the within said de mark
and I've always achieved the same
results I've never really had something
that deviated much from our known tables
dr. Connie Leonard our next question
could you please repeat what we're
images 10 and 11
images 10 and in Haven on slide
Oh images 10 and 11 those were our
marketing to get to it this is one of
our lines that we we struggle to make
stories with when we remove them from
the Agri wells they were as you can see
on image 9 they are not really that
nice-looking
so when we put them into the bioreactor
after six days they actually formed
beautiful round spherical aggregates and
that is that is what images 10 in lemon
is just to show you that after a while
the system the bioreactor system will
help your cells form
B squared
how do you know which cell lines can be
established as 3d spheroid models well
theoretically any any adherence sign
should be able to form a series with any
of the methods proposed however it's
important to study their known
characteristics and each line will need
to be optimized and adaptations to the
mesh method should be made
I've a question why do you only write to
you but thyroid cultures after 21 days
this is a very interesting question it's
a very important question so for this
I'm going to go back to slide 27 and on
slide 27 in figures D and if we notice
that from day 1 to 13 that is it that
there is a corresponding increase that
that the 3dr sorry the 3d cultures
corresponds well to the 2d cultures in
terms of the initial increase in birth
the ATP and the adenoma my kinase I'm
just going to say a K from now on this
is normal due to the excess
proliferating cells as well as the
growing cell number however between day
15 and 18 we see a transition in the in
the 3d cultures which we don't yet fully
understood so after day after day 18
when the cells according to the growth
curve which we do not show you um
reaches has a reduction in doubling time
there is an increase in the ATP in a
drastic decrease in the a K so this
system is not actively proliferating
however the ATP levels indicate that
there are still very much metabolically
active almost like the in vivo situation
so we work with the service at this
point as it offers us a more stable
system that will provide a more true
reflection of how an in vivo tissue or
organ will respond to it change within
the micro environment
you
the college in 21 days a general
reference standard no it's actually it's
the quite interesting standard so we
also do drug transport studies on Kakadu
cells in transport Lakes which is a 2.5
g system and we leave this cell for 21
days as the cells being presented with a
monolayer
and they start to express some peak
proteins and enzymes as well as micro VD
it is full it is as a B cells in at this
point start to remember who they are if
that makes sense because they actually
start to differentiate after this time
and this is because of trypsin ization
services in ski and and PHA in 2013 see
that you can see the list of a rig you
can see the list of publications at the
end of this one actually found that 4
cells and not just the cockatoos or the
see through a cell line to completely
recover from to personalization and
reconnect and establish cellular
communication they need around 18 to 21
days before they are fully recovered and
communicating with each other
have you step through scuse me have you
studied the impact of geological
properties of the materials on the cells
and no that will actually be a quite
interesting study to do it's like to
sodium alginate but usually sodium
alginate is an inert substance that is
why Jesus actually been used for quite a
long time in as a biocompatible system
they used it initially and fun and then
in 1980 to publish the article where
they used eyelid souls that they
encapsulated into sodium alternates and
transported into humans and for this
reason I decided on sodium alginate
because it does not interfere that we
know of whether with the spirit or with
your result but it should be something
that you you can look at it it's
something that I will add to my control
groups just to make sure that we do not
have interaction
that's probably dimension that you use
sodium algemene why do you prefer this
to prepare steroids this actually comes
down to what I just said so we look at
our research question and we look at our
available resources so this is why we
chose this so when I had I had a cell
line that I wanted to produce words with
using the Agora place but our resources
fought me to look for and not too
expensive alternative method to do it so
so sodium alginate is a very affordable
the natural hydrogel of a non animal
origin that is biocompatible it is
transparent that makes our imaging very
easy and the gel itself is porous
allowing for diffusion of nutrients and
waste so it's very easy to work with and
as I said it in it so you will have
business you will not have to worry that
your alternate won't interfere with your
data and alginate itself can be modified
in there that's a difficult word
according to your to your needs however
I was a suggest to use a
well-characterized and highly purified
alginate because if you do not use this
then you will have instances where they
do interfere with your with your data
if there are no more questions I would
like to want to thank you again dr.
Khalid do you have any final comments
for our audience no no that disposals
quite fun and if you have any questions
for me please feel for you feel free to
reach out I am on research gate linking
and and on Instagram we share some of
our nice service with me making the lab
on Instagram so yes oh and also the
guard for salvia
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
think again dr. Carla me carlitz
for her time today and her important
research we would also like to thank
levert and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through November of
2018 labret will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye